non mais moi je veux d'abord dire avant
d'évoquer zemmour le pen que je suis
assez effaré en tant que citoyen
français très attachés quand même à
l'histoire aux valeurs que défend notre
pays est un grand pays qu'est qui
apprécié dans le monde entier que les
thèmes de campagne qui officiera en ce
démarrage de la présidentielle sont des
thèmes mais qui sont
hallucinants de lamentable on parle des
prénoms on a parlé d oui mais eric
zemmour matin midi et soir c'est quand
même lui qui est la boussole des thèmes
de cette gamme à l'avocat d'eric zemmour
me procure dans vos désaccords quand
même et je vais y revenir vous n'avez
pas marqué quand même beaucoup de
désaccords avec lui je sens qu'à une
grande proximité la haine du musulman le
roger de l'immigré voilà le français
tonnerre sont aujourd'hui très commun si
je peux terminer mon propos en prêt je
trouve que le fonds de commerce comme m
bourassa normes nationales et à eric
zemmour c'est la haine des musulmans et
celle roger de l'immigré et je suis
désolé de vous le dire je pense que vous
êtes totalement à côté de la plaque la
première préoccupation des français
c'est le pouvoir d'achat vous avez dans
cette période-là on à l'augmentation du
gaz de l'électricité des français qui
ont des fins de mois difficiles
compper pour l'avenir de leurs enfants
de qui ça pas comme un solo journée des
travailleurs qui dorment dans leur
voiture et vous êtes dans une obsession
qui est celle de créer une fracture dans
le pays en pointant le musulman comme un
problème comme pour une grande amie
grêlons même après le musulman comme un
pied vous dire vous rendez compte qu'un
groupe picard un autre débat des prénoms
que les parents bébé
vous êtes à côté parce que c'est pareil
c'est pas le porte parole d'eric simon
lui c'est madame et
2,6 et même opposés à ça non mais
le pouvoir d'achat c'est une attitude
majeur du bassin mais on peut enfin
c'est terminé mais si je peux terminer
arrive mais c'est vrai que karim là sur
l'annoncé pas lui parler d'accord mais
merci de dire ça mais depuis tout à
l'heure on parle de zemmour
les thèmes les thèmes quand même porté
sur les mêmes vous n'avez pas parquer
votre désaccord 15 et moore avec son
approche pétainiste de la france nous
dit que pétain n'a pas
mis des judokas je l'avais dit faudra
répondre sur il c'est gravissime et ça
mais vous en fait si vous voulez si je
peux terminer vous faites du
révisionnisme zemmour et vous sur
l'histoire de france et vous avez un
fantasme mais quand le grand
remplacement à ça ce thème vous êtes
d'accord mais moi je vais vous dire le
grand emprunt cement il est en train de
le prendre en boomerang à la gueule
parce que si un recrutement ou remplacer
un grand remplacement il se situe à
l'extrême droite entre zemmour et vous
le reste du grand emplacement c'est un
fantasme ça n'existe pas je vais vous
dire il ya 6 millions de francs séjour
donne bardella d'un siècle dans ce pays
6 millions de musulmans en france et
plus qui ont qu'ils ont leur place à la
société française qui sont les
invisibles qui demande être banalisés
ils sont pointés du doigt sans arrêt
mais vous rendez compte l'image selon
jean moulin on peut il faut rendre des
comptes mais présenter ces médicaments
je vais vous dire donc je voulais
terminer mon propos avoir examiné que
pour moi vous et zemmour ouais vous
incarnez une france qui pour moi la
france de la honte face à une france ta
fin de la collaboration la france qui
est fantasmé qui une phrase de la
couleur de peau une phrase d origine du
frein de la religion ça c'est une france
qui est celle de la résistance des
lumières d'où l'ouverture du respect de
la république de la laïcité on a un
grand pays jordan bardella ne réduisez
pas avoué zemmour date en train de les
tricks et de le rendre petit c est moi
je vais vous dire j'espère que les
françaises et les français étaient direz
vous être ouvert que les françaises et
les français
été condamné voilà je suis est sûre lady
gibles vous êtes sinon je relis
présentez vous à l'abri des noms si vous
êtes sur le même faute de commerces
variés qui arrive vous rappelle rémy
pourtant les cas je suis en argot et
nous attendons le 17 novembre mais on
aura dans ce jeu
laisse moi juste des cas karim eux
je comprends tout à fait là ce que vous
dites mais juste lui en plus ce qu'il
vient de dire c'est qu'on contraire lui
il voit un second tour marine le pen
emmanuel macron c'est moi qui lui parle
d'eric zemmour depuis tout à l'heure
parce que la question est la première
question qu'on se pose ce soir c est ce
que eric zemmour est en train de
siphonner les électeurs de marine le pen
c'est pour ça qu'on en a parlé mais lui
les prénoms alors je suis plus je
défends pas jordan bardella mais je lui
dis voilà oui la dissimilation
s'immiscer dans l'assimilation et c'est
bien
là tout ce que dit zemmour
c'est voilà c'est ça c'est pour l'invité
ce soir j'espère qu'on l'aura exclusive
ça non mais s'il vous plaît mais voilà
mais là c'est vrai que lui quand vous
dites vous réduisez le débat politique
entre zemmour et marine le pen l'a
surtout là c'est juste la question
puisque on s'est dit on et emmanuel
macron pour l'instant il sort un voilà
il est pour l'instant mais promis on va
voir si ça va durer mais pour l'instant
c'est lui qui passe au second tour on
cherche le candidat qui va se retrouver
face à emmanuel macron et on se poser la
question est ce que eric zemmour va
passer devant marine le pen c'est tout
moi je dis simplement que je sais c'est
un grand remplacement voilà c'est ça que
tu prendras chose à l'enjeu parce que
votre fantasme de grands emplacements
pour cent en train de le subir c'est ça
voilà s'il se passer s'il a lieu il
n'aura d'yeux qu'alexandra c'est une
forte pente parce que bien donc je suis
pétainiste
j'ai la haine vous n'avez pas dit votre
différence avec lui sur mes terres
j'arrive sur lui noté
mettant pardon vous voulez que je vous
pourquoi voulez que je vous parle de
péter parce que zemmour en parler on
vous aime je fais ma boussole politique
n'ose avancer de légende et bardella vos
différences avec j'aime à penser que
n'avait pas évoqué ce pan de l'histoire
de frapper parce que je préfère évoluer
l intéresse les gens non je suis pas
d'accord car que la france elle était à
londres voyez mais je ne cherche ni à
réhabiliter le régime de vichy né à
minimiser la responsabilité de la france
parce que pour moi la france elle était
à londres et que le général de gaulle
l'accord en charge et vous pensez à
toujours été sur cette ligne est-ce que
vous pensez que les gens qui se lèvent
le matin
se questionne sur la responsabilité de
pétain m'enfin vous d'élire ils sont
insensibles et justement sur le mois non
mais ils vont pouvoir envoyer leurs
gamins à l'école en sécurité les gens
ils ont le sentiment c'est vrai vous
avez évoqué la question du grand
emplacement c'est vrai ne vous en
déplaise il ya des gens qui suivirent ça
vous n'avez jamais travaillé à des gens
qui ont le sentiment ont le sentiment
excuser les uns mais qui ont le
sentiment de ne plus reconnaître le pays
dans lequel ils ont grandi mais s'ils
sont adroits ils ont grandi l'on vous
remet approfondissons c'est quoi c'est
quoi c'est quoi le pays dans son grenier
je veux dans ses innombrables quartier
karim zéribi où nos concitoyens wii ne
reconnaissent plus leur pays et ont le
sentiment qu'il ya des gens qui arrivent
dans notre pays aujourd'hui non pas pour
le chérir non pas pour l'aimer mais pour
le changer
le classement il pointe une réalité vous
fait vous venez avec moi je venais avec
moi que j'ai grandi à saint denis à
aubervilliers
mais bobigny vous voyez d'être seul à
l'ailé dans les cales et combien de
villages vous êtes
sur une autre planète